Should a person spit having rinsed or
washed his mouth out generally or after
making woodoo? Normally when people fast
there are some people who think that
after you goggle your mouth with water
or rinse your mouth with water then they
should spit out because you know maybe
some water will be followed. But the
general ruling is that most of the
scholars agree that once you gargle the
mouth and after expulsion of the water
from the mouth there's no need to spit.
It's not a requirement. And even those
few scholars who say you should spit
it's only once. But there are some
people who spit several times. Some
people even take a cloth and they dry
their mouth you know after goggling
thinking that the water will you know go
into the stomach which is absurd because
normally when we see and we read the s
of the prophet and the lifestyle of the
sahabas many a times when they drank
water just before fudar before beginning
the fast when they heard the fajar aan
they stopped drinking but we have never
heard of any saba spitting out after
drinking water if you have to spit while
goggling the People when they have water
just before starting the fast at the end
of the sur when they had the aan surely
some hadith would have said that the
sabas they spat you know so that the
water doesn't go into which is not seen
and while in woodoo when you gole the
mouth rinse the mouth and you expel the
water that's it even if you have to spit
maximum I think once is sufficient you
can't go beyond that spitting several
times and you know taking a cloth and
drying your mouth everything else that
remains can be counted as part of the
saliva. There's no problem at all. You
can't make life difficult for you.
It's good to know that actually it would
make life very difficult when one was
fasting if we had to do that. Thank you
very much Dr. Zakia.